الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا قد يكون
احد اكثر الزلازل تسببا في وقوع ضحايا
خلال السنوات العشر الماضيه حيث اكتسبب في
صدى يمتد طوله لما يزيد على 100 كم بين
الصفيحه الاناضوليه والصفيحه العربيه
صدعوا شرق الانادول هو خط زلزلي عباره عن
كسر في الصخور يؤدي الى انزلاقات زلزاليه
تتدافع بموجبها الواح صخريه صلبه على
امتداد خط الصدى الراسي ما يؤدي الى زياده
ضغوط حتى تنزلق احداها في النهايه في حركه
تفضي الى اطلاق قدر هائل من الطاقه التي
يمكن ان تتسبب في حدوث زلزال كان مركز
الزلزال على بعد 26 كيلومترا تقريبا شرقي
مدينه نورداي التركيه وعلى عمق نحو 18
كيلو مترا عند فالق شرق الاناضول واطلق
زلزال موجات باتجاه الشمال الشرقي ما تسبب
في حدوث دمار في وسط تركيا وسوريا وبلغ
متوسط الزلازل التي تتجاوز قوتها درجات
اقل من 20 زلزالا على مر التاريخ ما يجعل
زلزال اليوم حدثا خطيرا ولم يسجل نفس قوه
زلزال اليوم سوى زلزالين فقط من اكثر
الزلازل فتكا في الفتره من 2013 الى 2022